hey what's happening i thought i'd shoot
a quick video getting a lot of people
asking me
about house prices what's happening
house prices are actually from january
up until now
they've actually very very slightly
dropped they're dipped so people are
saying
our house price is about to crash are
they about to
you know fall now is it the time um i
know a lot of people were saying in 2020
in fact i myself said in 2020
that i thought that 2021 we were going
to see a crash
so do i still think that what's
happening what's the property market
currently doing
and what our house price is expected to
do in the next
few months or throughout the end of the
year so that's what i'm doing in this
video
um listen if you enjoy my channel i
spend a lot of time researching stuff
like this spend an awful lot of time
um you know studying researching
researching for myself
but also for you who are subscribed to
my channel so do me a big favor if you
enjoy my videos
if you appreciate the time i put into
researching these types of topics
just smash the like button hit like and
also drop a comment below
as well so first thing i want to say is
this um
last year 2020 as we all know
we had a really really rough year
because of the
pandemic because of the lockdown um at
time
at times the property market was frozen
and
i predicted that house prices would
actually go up
i did a video back around june time
where i predicted that house prices
january 2021
were going to be significantly higher
than they were june time
my predictions were very accurate
and that was great however i also
predicted
back in june 2020 that 2021
we were going to see the house housing
market go down
significantly now so far in 2021 it has
dropped
so i guess technically um you know i was
correct
but um i don't think house prices are
about to go down dramatically i've
changed my mind
uh and the reason i've changed my mind
is just because the circumstances have
changed so what's happened is
everything's been pushed back furlough's
being pushed back
uh stamp duty holiday has been pushed
back everything's been pushed back the
lockdown's been pushed back
and because of that i think that the
housing crash
is also going to be put back and i think
that
considering that until september 2021
um we've still got stamp duty holiday
we've still got the furlough scheme so
people aren't
um you know being made losing their jobs
and not being able to eat
as as as as probably will happen in time
so listen everything's been put back i
think that house prices this year
are going to be pretty stable because
the government are making that the case
with the incentives that are in place
however
i do think that
once the furlough scheme finishes
once the stam duty holiday finishes i
think the house prices are going to go
down
i think we're going to see a big a big
fall in properties
however as i said before i don't think
that's a big deal
this is the thing right it's so funny
because last year when i was saying
my prediction of house prices i was so
spot on i trying to
remain as humble as possible but it's
hard when you're so right again and
again
um but last year if you look at my
videos
i actually i actually specified how much
no one usually does this
usually people um are very vague with
their with their predictions if they
make predictions at all
i mean the media usually get it wrong
everybody forgets
but i was so i was so smack on right
with my prediction of what the house
prices would be
in in january almost almost two
to a pound but but the thing is as soon
as i was right
and it's like oh wow look at this like i
published it and i showed what i said
and
what's happened now everybody said what
what are they going to do now though
what's going to be next and i think
people are so obsessed with
what our house price is going to do
they're so obsessed with that because
people think that the way to make money
is to buy a house
and then wait for it to go up but that's
not how you make money in property
you don't buy a house and wait for it to
go up
that's why one of the first rules on the
property investors crash course
is capital appreciation doesn't pay the
bills
capital appreciation doesn't pay the
bills so i think that people that are
obsessed with my opinion
and other people's opinions on exactly
what house prices are going to do
those people are obsessed with that are
probably needing
to change their mind on what is
important and i'll tell you what's
important what's important is
when you buy a property oh man i'm
loving this son isn't it great
the clocks have just changed it's like
almost evening time
it's absolutely beautiful and what's
important is not
what house prices are going to do and
i'll tell you why that's not important
it's not important
number one because you can't predict
that for sure you can't know exactly
what
house prices are going to do for sure
but number two is because
capital appreciation literally
doesn't pay the bills now what i mean by
that is if you buy a house for 100 grand
and then very quickly it's worth 200
grand that 100 000 pounds in equity
okay i mean unless you're gonna sell the
house i mean sure you could refinance it
but it's nice to know all right my net
worth went up but it doesn't pay the
bills
what pays the bills and the answer is
your rent
your rent is what pays the bill so when
you buy property rather than thinking
what's it gonna do is it gonna go up
it's gonna go down you're better off and
you'll be much smarter
and this is what's gonna get you through
the recession by the way you're better
off to think
how much is this gonna pay me every
month because if you buy a property for
100 grand
and it's paying you a profit of a
thousand pounds a month
and then it drops and it's only worth 80
grand but it's still paying you a
thousand pounds a month
are you gonna sell it no are you gonna
care
no why because it's giving you a monthly
income if you buy a property for a
hundred thousand pounds
and it's paying you nothing if it's
costing you
and then it doubles in value are you
gonna sell it yeah you're gonna get rid
of it
so it's all about cash flow cash cash is
not king
cash flow is king capital appreciation
isn't king
cash flow is king so when you buy a
property you want to get as much cash
flow
as possible and how you're going to do
that well i would suggest
not only buying glow and renting high
but i would also suggest buying a
property and splitting it up
into hmr meaning a house of multiple
occupancy
meaning a property that you rent out
room
by room that gives cash flow
that gives good cash flow now the great
thing about buying properties and
turning into a hmo
is they're changing the rules they're
bringing article 4 in
which means you're not going to be able
to do that anymore for much longer so
what i would highly recommend you do
is i would highly recommend you find
properties
that are in non-article four areas i'm
actually looking for something that's
why i'm wandering around the house
all right you'll find out what it is in
a minute um i've got a gift i've got a
gift for you basically
i've got a gift and i'm looking around
the house for it and when i found it
you'll get it
um so i recommend buying a house
in a non-article four area
renting it out room by room not only is
that going to give you really good cash
flow but here's the great part
it's going to give you really good cash
flow but also when they bring
article 4 into the area you're going to
have
automatic planning permission
okay to run it as a hmo which means
you're going to get forced
capital appreciation you don't have to
wait for capital appreciation
you can force capital appreciation by
buying glow renting high
but then also increasing the value by
buying smart i found the gift
here's the gift this is for you new
shocked i'm going to be giving this away
you can't believe it
and you can't believe it it's the gift
the gift is
if you haven't read it read it by low
i mean look this book this book
summarizes
everything i know about property top 12
years experience
is this little book it's not big book
it's an easy to read book
so i'd highly recommend get your hands
on this and the gift is of course you're
going to get this for free
so i'm going to leave in the i'm going
to leave the house right now because i
can hear my little boy crying
i've got three kids now having three
kids is a different story
and having two kids no it's a gang now
it's a whole gang it's a posse
um so yeah this book has changed a lot
of people's lives
and i wrote this a few years ago and in
this book i talk about hmos
and as hmo has become a thing of the
past in years to come
they'll become extinct for most people
but not for you because when you get hmo
now
you have the grandfather right meaning
that you have i can still hear him can
you hear him
meaning that you have the right to rent
out hmo forever and nobody else does
it's going to make your hmo special
edition it's going to push up the price
it's going to push up the rent you need
to get hmos so
this this book you can get a copy of
this i'm going to leave a link in the
description where you can get a copy for
free
on the house you just have to pay for
your posting package inc but
i won't get a penny from sending you
this book so get get a copy on the house
i'll send it to your house
and sometimes i like to be the postman
sometimes i literally just turn up in
people's houses and say hey here's your
book
so you never know i might turn up at
your house
um but i'll leave as i said i'll leave a
link in the description
get claim your copy it's absolutely free
why am i giving it away for free
because i want you to make take take
advantage of the situation right now
in the uk and i want you to become
wealthy
buying properties low renting them high
that's not unethical
you know some people get upset with me
oh you bite though and then you rent it
high and you force people to pay
you're not forcing anyone to pay
anything business is creating
solutions for people creating win-win
situations
what you're doing is you're buying low
and then you're changing the use of the
property by splitting it up
and renting you on as a hmo by offering
affordable accommodation for people
but rather than renting it to one person
you're entering it to four
or five or six or seven
and getting paid a lot more than you
would if you rented out as a single
layer
so get the book enjoy it and i'll look
forward to seeing you real soon
subscribe to the channel and uh see you
on the other side
enjoy